[Music]
the great american beer festival also
known as the distant fathers expo
every year hundreds of people come to
beer festivals like this one to see what
it's like to not drink alone
yes this is the opposite of aaa
this is alcoholics conspicuous
it's also a craft beer festival yes
there are thousands of unnecessary micro
brews on display here
but when it comes right down to it any
one of these beers will make you more
racist
oh i'm here with the guy from the
pringles can
where are you from rochester new york
flew all the way in from denver uh we're
drinking some beers today and uh when
you came on your antique tricycle i see
you don't mass produce this no we don't
we do a few kegs at a time right and we
call that small batch brewing i see that
you also bathe in small batches
he has an odor
brewing beer is like making love to
madonna at this age
yeah
it's it takes a lot of time and patience
you've got to keep stirring and stirring
and uh at the end there's way more yeast
than you thought there'd be
all right let's see what you got here
that's a nice head yeah the last time i
saw i had this frothy i was getting
blown by a with rabies
now what's this tweezer nail tell me
about tweezer nails it's gluten-free
it's certified gluten-free with
strawberry puree delicious buckwheat
honey gluten-free yeah
gluten-free beer i don't wanna i don't
wanna try it i just want to uh sniff the
area where your balls used to be
now tell me is is an essential uh
component in making craft beer uh to
resemble the radish
okay
i'm getting a note some tobacco
uh
stale fruit
uh garlic
oh wait a minute
no that's you i'm sorry
what's your name i'm larry and from
south carolina
wow oh this is a very fancy craft brewer
yes
tell me
looking at you you're an expert i'm sure
what beer
pairs best with a tv dinner and a broken
marriage
you have a great look with the hats too
besides craft brewing how long have you
been pursuing moby dick
yes
[Music]
seriously this is awful if you want
someone to taste your piss so badly you
should start dating kesha
okay i'm here with your brewing company
lone tree viewing company yes it's the
beer company that's named after what you
hit on the way home
fish brewing company that's a real name
you're a bunch of losers these names are
never going to work
here i've got some names you pay
attention
all the good hobbies were taken lager
this is why i'm morbidly stout stout
gay after three beers
start a fight with your lawn jockey ale
and by the end of the night i'll say the
n word longer
how you doing
it's very sweet how old is she
ten months my goodness we've got one
adorable one here and right here we have
another one on the way
isn't that great
don't drink it's not good for the baby
and you uh and so you're trying out a
lot of beers yes you consider yourself a
good judge of beers yes because you
certainly aren't a good judge of food
portions
i did it again i made a joke about his
girl
check it out women these are the only
girls here
i've seen a better male to female ratio
at the vatican
all right i'm talking to paul
now this man uh you're a beer judge i am
a beard so you judged a bunch of beers
today i do 4 800 beers so you're a
connoisseur of microbrews yes microbials
that's very interesting because i
consider myself a connoisseur of
pretentious jag-offs and i find you
fascinating
you want to hear a joke i do a micro
brew connoisseur walks into a bar and he
says to the bartender give me your
finest pumpkin ale but make sure it's
not too hoppy
so the bartender takes out a baseball
bat and beats him senseless while
everyone cheers
yeah i think the second beer here in
front of us has a little more caramelly
malts in it believe it or not they
actually have classes here in
microbrewing you know china is beating
the out of us and we're learning
about craft beer
wanna respect beer i'll show you some
beer you should respect
right here baby
right here
there we go
[Applause]
now we got something you are a beer
judge yes wow what kind of fancy is
this that you're making everyone drink
what's so special about it this has
those apricots in it
oh apricots
oh look at me yummy apricots cricket
get it in there
that's fear man here you can use this
for your class just take it
take the arm everything it's all yours
[Music]
[Applause]
are you okay are you all right i think
we need the breathalyzer all right
so there it is
oh yes
oh yes oh yes
[Applause]
0.5 which is pretty much what she blows
every night
who's with me
colorado rocks yes
wait a minute we're in colorado
yeah what are we doing at the beer
festival
[Applause]
[Music]
cash barrier did that platinum coast
purple haze not bad blue dreams okay all
right okay blue drain yeah bigger the
big bigger bigger you're gonna need a
lot of bigger that's more more come on
get louder
come to colorado folks for an
unforgettable experience which you will
never remember
[Applause]
really not a good journalist he's really
compromised as a journalist